brian we've been talking about this for
a while hybrid learning begins in less
than three weeks for some
students within the clark county school
district they'll be attending
in person two days and then remotely
three days a week eight news now
reporter kristen drummond joining us in
the newsroom with a breakdown of data
from a recent survey
about who exactly wants to go back
kristen denise the survey revealing more
than
50 percent of lower elementary school
families and staff
plan to come back in buildings but it
does not seem to reflect the reality of
each campus
obviously it wasn't 50 percent of our
school marie arsenal tells me her
grandson attends harmon elementary
school
she says administration informed her
hardly any students plan to return
there's only a small handful of
kids that are doing the hybrid at our
school
i mean like under 15. likely not the
case
district-wide the survey results show
about 56 percent of ccsd students
between pre-kindergarten to third grade
plan to come back
while the other 44 percent will continue
full-time distance education
responses were submitted by 75 percent
of the 85
000 students in the lower elementary
grade levels
why do you want to continue distance
education i think
for my grandson it's the best fit right
now
i took the survey i want my kids to go
back asap josh curtis counts down
sending his kindergartner and first
grader back in buildings on march
1st they definitely need some social
interaction they need
they need to be around other children
are you worried two of your children
will not have the same teacher
no not as much an employee survey shows
nearly 60 percent of staff want to work
on campus
while roughly 40 percent prefer still
working remotely
each school gets to determine which
educators come back
based on the number of students who want
to return we got to put our foot in the
doorway and start somewhere but
arsenal would rather continue online
learning even if it's the minority
preference
he knows the whole routine i reached out
to harman elementary school but was told
to contact the district
i also requested a breakdown of each
school from the district but have not
received an answer yet
ccsd says elementary schools will share
plans for transitioning to hybrid
learning
as well as continuing full-time distance
education reporting live in the newsroom
kristen drummond 8 news now